[Music]
[Music]
hey y'all i
am christy wright and i'm so excited to
be hanging out with you guys for the
next little bit
as we are going to have this free live
session where we we are talking all
about
balance we are going to be talking about
life balance
what gets in the way of us feeling
balanced because we know there's a lot
of things
and we're going to be talking about what
to do about it
and so i'm so excited because i'm also
going to save some time at the end
to answer your questions so if you're
watching on facebook
if you're watching on youtube if you're
watching on twitch which i just learned
about 10 minutes ago
welcome i'm so glad you guys are here
you can put your questions
in the chat and i'm gonna save some time
at the end so be sure to stick around
and i hopefully will get to your
question and we'll get through a lot of
them
because i know this is a really really
hard subject and it's something that we
all need help with
myself included now let's start by just
acknowledging
that this is hard this is one of those
things that we
love to talk about but at the same time
we always feel like we're
failing we always feel like we never get
there we don't even know what balance is
we're just sure we don't have it and so
i want to spend some time tonight
talking about what balance is
what it isn't and what gets in the way
of us being able to feel balanced now i
want to start by sharing a story with
you and some of you
may have heard me share this story
before but about six years ago six and a
half years ago i had this moment
and it was in the spring it was about um
i guess february
is 2015 and i had just had my first
child
carter and i was going through all the
emotions of being a new mom you're
exhausted you're sleep deprived
you don't even know what you're doing
you're like i can't believe
they let me leave the hospital with this
tiny person like do they know
that i don't know what to do with it
like you feel like you're doing
something wrong
from the get-go i remember thinking like
i'm such a poser i just kept waiting for
like the real mom to sweep in
and like know what to do and i remember
those first
six weeks in particular were really
really hard they weren't just hard
because this was new and they weren't
just hard because i was sleep deprived
they were all so hard because
we were having a really hard time with a
few different things with carter from
his skin to getting him to nurse and
just several things
going on that will really were really
difficult well there was one night in
particular
and this was like 2 a.m in the morning
and i was in the nursery and i was
trying
to get carter to eat i was trying to
nurse him and it just wasn't working and
he was crying and screaming and i was
i started crying i was so tired and i
just felt so
defeated i remember thinking i don't
know what i'm doing
but i definitely am not doing this right
because if i was doing it right
this wouldn't be so hard if i was doing
it right my baby wouldn't be crying like
this
and if i was if i was doing this right
this would not feel so emotional and
difficult for me
and i started crying sobbing with my son
as i sat there felt so frustrated that i
didn't know what to do and my husband
was in the other room and he you know
had the monitor in there and
when he heard not one but two voices
crying out in the monitor he he jumped
out of bed and came around and he stood
in the doorway and he saw
me sitting there in the glider holding
my son my son carter
holding him and just crying we're both
just crying and he could tell that we
were fine
you know he knew what was going on that
moment and he just stood there and he
didn't ask any questions
he just stood in the doorway and he just
said five words to me
he said you're doing a good job
and i just cried even harder because i
wanted
so bad for that to be true and it felt
like it was
anything but true and he said it again
you're doing a good job
and i just kept crying he said you're
doing
a good job
what was so powerful about that moment
for me was not that it was a compliment
like hey
you look great you're doing a good job
it wasn't that at all what was so
powerful about that moment
was that what my husband said to me in
that moment
was the truth i was doing a good job
i just didn't know it because you know
what
i had a voice in my head that said i was
doing a bad job
that i wasn't doing a good job that i
was failing all day
every day that broken record in the back
of my mind you're failing
you're screwing this up you're not a
good mom you're half asleep at work you
forgot that project
you forgot to do that and your house is
a mess and you haven't had a shower in
four days your hair is greasy girl like
you
are failing have you ever been there
you make one misstep and that voice in
your head just piles it on and you
forgot this
and you forgot this and this and this
and this and before you know it
you feel buried beneath the narrative
that you're failing that you're somehow
getting it wrong
but if you were getting it right it
wouldn't be this hard if you're getting
it right you wouldn't be this tired if
you were getting it right
you would be more confident in your life
than this
i've been there i know that feeling i
know that feeling
of feeling like you're failing and to be
honest
that's not one of those things you flip
a switch and it's over
i had a situation last night true story
y'all last night
my husband and i were going to bed and i
was telling him about something that had
happened earlier in the day yesterday
after our
video shoot with the panel and it was a
small misstep on my part it was a
complete accident but as i told him
my eyes filled with tears because that
feeling came back over me
i'm failing and he said those words to
me again
you're doing a good job you're doing a
good job
so before we even get in to our teaching
tonight
i just i just want to make sure you know
that
i'd love to help you with your calendar
i've got all kinds of notes and we're
going to answer questions and i have
tips
and advice to help you have more balance
i'm good at that and i love to research
it and i love to live it out
but before we even get into the
practical and tactical i want to start
with the most
basic truth not a compliment
a truth about you and i know this
you're doing a good job
already let that be the foundation
we build this teaching on because i know
that you like me like everyone by the
way
struggle with this heavy and exhausting
belief
that you're not i want to be a person
that tells you that you are
i know that voice can get loud i know
that the pressure can pile on and you've
got this
this pressure to do more and so we think
like oh i feel like i'm failing so i
just need to
do more i need to wake up earlier i need
to work out more i need to run faster i
need to multitask
i need to be more efficient i need a new
app a new planner i need a new
system yeah that's gonna solve my
balance problem and we run
harder and we run faster and we wake up
earlier and we go to bed later and we
just
rush so fast in between and we try
so hard to keep up
and we still feel out of balance
and by the way we're exhausted so i
don't know
maybe we're missing something y'all
maybe the solution
isn't to run harder maybe the solution
isn't to multitask more
maybe the solution isn't more efficiency
and productivity those are not bad
things
but maybe they're not the solution to
what's going on in your head
and your heart maybe these external
symptoms these external solutions are
not
the real solution to what's going on
inside
of you that feeling that you're not
enough that feeling that you're failing
that feeling that you can't get it
together
and you never will maybe
it's something else you know when i ask
people
what does life balance mean to you i get
a variety of answers all over the map
uh we've got all kinds of definitions
well it's a 50 50 split well it's having
enough rest what's having time for
yourself it's self-care
i get so many answers and none of them
are bad i think
many of them are partially true but what
i've found is
we don't have one definition of balance
but what's interesting is even though we
don't know what balance is
we are positive that we don't have it
isn't that interesting
like we don't know what it is we just
know we don't have it so it becomes this
thing that haunts us almost like a
shadow because we're just convinced that
no matter what we do
we're doing it wrong no matter what we
do
we're somehow falling short we're
somehow missing the mark there's
something we need to
do more to feel balanced and then we
have this idea of all these formulas you
know
it's a 50 50 split it's like this it's
like a scale
or you balance it all balance home and
work
or we think that it's this idea that
we're just going to do everything for an
equal amount of time like imagine a pie
and all the slices of the pie are
perfectly equal
and we've got time for work and time for
rest and time with god and time with
friends and time with our spouse and
time with our kids
and time for self-care and time for
everything perfectly every day
and we just live in a zen state um
does that ever happen to you that's
never happened to me my whole life so if
that's balanced yet no
no we're not gonna get there not like
this not with the pie not in your zen
state
no that's not it either
it's not doing everything for an equal
amount of time because we can't do that
we can't and we won't so all we do
is beat ourselves up because we set
ourselves up to fail because we're
chasing a finish line
that always moves and every time i'm
asked this question
i'm always asked it in the same way how
do you balance
it all how do you balance everything
you have going on balance is always used
as a verb
how do you balance it all and we've got
all the analogies right like we've got
spinning plates we've got juggling balls
and some balls are rubber and some are
glass
and we're also walking a tightrope and
all by the way have a whole lot of fun
and just be relaxed in your life
i don't know about you but none of those
activities sound
relaxing they don't feel like this
this is me at my best self walking in
tight ropes spinning plates and juggling
balls trying to discern which ones are
glass and rubber
that's not stressful y'all it sounds
full of anxiety have you ever seen a
juggler that doesn't look fun
that looks hard it looks risky it looks
stressful
it also looks like something that you
can work really hard at
and still feel out of balance
you can spin all the plates you can
juggle all the balls you can walk the
tightrope
and still feel like something's missing
still feel like that something is wrong
what if what if we're asking the wrong
question
what if we're asking the wrong question
which leads us to do the wrong things we
say how do i balance it all and because
we think it's a balancing act
we need to walk straighter spin more
plates
juggle more efficiently get all the apps
and just
work really really hard if we could just
pull ourselves up by our bootstraps
then we would nail that balance
what if we're asking the wrong question
what if balance isn't something you do
what if it's something you create
what if it's something you become
what if balance is less like an activity
that you perform and more like a feeling
that you create where
you could be balanced and still busy
where you could create a sense of
balance
even in a world very out of balance
where balance looks less like an acrobat
or a juggler
and more like peace
confidence enjoying your life
where you feel peace even in chaotic
times a
centeredness where you feel confident in
your choices when you say yes to this
thing and no to that thing you feel
confident
in that choice where you finally shake
the guilt that's been nagging at you for
so long and you
actually wait for it enjoy your life
where you're proud of how you spend
your time don't you want that
i do and i think
that when we seek balance when we say i
need more balance i need more work-life
balance i need to
balance it better that's what we're
really after
that that peace that confidence
being happy in your life and proud
of how you're spending your life
we can't balance it all perfectly
we were never meant to balance we were
created
to be balanced we can be a balanced
person
in an out of balance world and watch how
that simple shift not only changes your
activities and behaviors
you're not running faster because you
realize that's actually not the solution
but instead it does have a ripple effect
in your calendar in your relationships
in even how you experience yourself
because that feeling
that lie that you've been failing
gets a little bit quieter and a little
bit quieter
until eventually it fades into the
background almost completely
but when it creeps up again you know
what to do about it what if that's the
type of balance
we're actually looking for life balance
is not
a 50 50 split and it's not doing
everything for an equal amount of time
it's about doing the right things at the
right time
and when you do the right things at the
right time you
feel the sense of balance you've been
looking for
all along but if you're gonna do that
if you're going to do what i believe is
the truest way
to feel balance if you're gonna do the
right things at the right time well you
need to know
what's gonna get in the way of your
being able to do that
right like you're gonna need to know
what are the obstacles and challenges
what keeps you
right now from doing that from doing the
right things the right time we want to
but so often we don't so why not
well when you go to drive somewhere for
example let's say you get your car
you're going to a new destination you
probably
pull up your gps on your phone or in
your car
and you plug in your destination your
gps is going to show you several routes
and it's going to show you
the best route to get to where you want
to go and avoid all the traffic
and all the construction and all the
obstacles that might get in your way
on the way to your destination well
that's what i want to do tonight
i want to give you four main causes
that keep you from doing the right
things at the right time
that keep you from creating your version
of balance in your life and i want to
give you a quick
overview of these and then before we
wrap up of course i will answer your
questions because i want to respect
your time as well there are four main
causes
that keep us from doing the right things
at the right time these are four
reasons that we feel out of balance and
you may relate to some
more than others you might relate to
multiples that's totally fine but if
you're tracking with me i want you to
think as i talk
which one or multiple ones hit home the
most with you
okay i can tell you for me i know which
ones hit home with me
all right number one reason number one
that we feel out of balance
we're doing too many things now some of
you are like okay that's obvious no
listen to me our time is finite
we get 24 hours in a day and as long as
you try to cram more
into that 24 hours then that time
can hold you're gonna be rushed anxious
stressed no fun by the way and out of
balance
it's kind of like me when i go to
grocery shopping i don't know if you're
like this but i go grocery shopping
and it doesn't matter if i get like two
bags of groceries
or like 25 bags of groceries when i come
home i do the same thing every time
i open the back of my trunk and i look
at this whole car
full of groceries milk gatorade orange
juice
heavy stuff people i look at that i go
i can get it one trip oh yeah i totally
got this and i start
loading up the bags all the way up to my
shoulder i'm putting all the bags on by
the time that i'm actually walking in
the house my arms are so full of plastic
bags full of groceries
my wrists the veins are bulging out it's
turning blue i'm trying to walk in like
the incredible hulk
what happens every time a bag breaks
every time the salsa is breaking on the
pavement the apple's rolling down the
street
i am frustrated and irritated and why
because i was never meant to carry that
much
at one time and as long as you try to do
too many things you will always feel
exhausted frustrated with yourself that
you're not doing it all
as well as you want to and very very
out of balance the second way that you
get out of balance is actually the total
opposite
you're not doing enough things now i'd
be willing to bet some of you tuning in
are like uh is that possible yes it is
let me give you some examples of someone
this might relate to and maybe this is
some of you watching right now
last year when the pandemic hit many of
us all of us
most of us unless you were an essential
worker were sent home
and at first we kind of loved it like oh
my gosh i can wear yoga pants all day i
can go for a run in the afternoon
but after about three weeks we were over
it
we were bored now that's an extreme
example but you might be in a season of
life
where you don't have things to show up
for maybe for the first time ever your
kids are off to college
and you're a new empty nester maybe
you're newly retired and you have all
this time that you don't know what to do
with
and you are feeling like something is
missing
you're feeling out of balance in a
completely opposite way because if you
don't have
relationships to connect with and
outlets to use your gifts and
responsibilities to show up for whatever
that may be
you're gonna be bored and out of balance
so the first reason is doing too many
things the second is not doing enough
things
the third reason we feel out of balance
is that we're doing the wrong
things what are the wrong things
you decide what is not important to you
what do you not care about but you spend
a lot of time there
i'll give you an extreme example because
i love those for making my point you
know
um let's say that you work in a
full-time job that you hate
in a toxic work culture when i walk you
through my steps in the path to balance
for example in my book when i walk you
through and we get to the step on
creating a calendar
and you put that on your calendar it
doesn't matter
how perfectly we manage your calendar if
you spend a
large percentage of your time doing
something that you hate
you're gonna feel out of balance because
you're doing something you hate
people you get one life you can't spend
a lot of time in your one life on things
you hate and expect to be happy and
balanced
balance is doing the right things at the
right time what is right for you
what is important to you when you do the
wrong things
you're always going to feel like things
are off because they are
because you're spending your one life on
things you don't care about
when you do the wrong things you feel
out of balance and then
fourth and this is slightly different
not
doing the right things the fourth reason
we feel out of balance is not doing the
right things now this is slightly
different than doing the wrong things
i hear people say things like this all
the time i love to work out
but i don't ever have the time to i want
to go on a date with my spouse
or a vacation but we can never make it
work we can never make our schedule sign
up man i'd love to start a business
but i don't ever have the time to i want
to play with my kids but i don't have
the energy
this but this this but this i want to do
this but this
listen if you don't spend time
in your one life on what you actually
care about
you're gonna be stressed and frustrated
and resentful
and anxious and angry because there's a
disconnect
in your life between what you care about
and when your life actually reflects
my goal for you is to bridge that gap
i want to help you do the right things
at the right time
and here's the great news you get to
decide what that is
you get to decide what's important to
you you get to decide what matters
most to you i'm not going to tell you
what you should do with your time
i'm going to do what i believe good
coaches do i'm going to help you figure
that out for yourself
and then show you the steps that you
need to practically
live it out in your life so you can do
the right things
at the right time before we go into the
questions i'd love to give you a
practical action step
okay this is super practical if you're
taking notes you can write it down if
not
you can remember and do it later here's
a very powerful question that you can
ask yourself
to help you start to process this to
identify
what are the four which of the four
causes do you connect with the most are
you doing too many things or not enough
things
are you doing the wrong things or you're
not doing the right things identify
which one of those might get in the way
but here's what i want you to do next
i want you to ask yourself a question
and it's very simple
but it's very powerful what's right
right now what's right right now
what is right for me right now now
here's what i mean by
right now right now is in this season
because what's right for you right now
in this season is probably different
than what was right for you six months
ago
six years ago will be six months from
now
because your season often determines
what's important to you
if you're in a busy season at work like
i am i got here at 6 45 y'all it's i
don't know i don't have a
7 20 now it's a long day this is a busy
season at work
and you know what that's right for me
right now
your season will often determine what's
right for you maybe you're in a season
of recovering from a surgery you're in a
season of a challenge with one of your
kids and you have to be really hands-on
with one of your kids
a season with a family member a season
financially a season where you're just
playing
and going on vacation you're taking your
foot off the gas you get to decide
what's right right now think about your
season
and then get more specific think about
your week maybe your season is this
theme but this week
is this theme this week here's what's
right right now
and even each individual day you can
start your day by asking yourself that
what's right right now what's right
right now guess what
only you can decide that this is your
one
life no one gets to tell you what should
be important to you or what you
should spend your time and your life on
you get to decide what's right for you
and when you do the right things
at the right time you will be creating
your
version of life balance and by the way
that's the only version of life balance
that should matter to you anyway
so ask yourself what's right right now
what's right right now here's what's so
beautiful about this question
when you ask yourself what's right right
now and you spend your time on
those things or that thing it helps you
shake the guilt
for not doing all the things that are
not right right now
you didn't do that you didn't do that my
house is a wreck i didn't work out today
i haven't seen my kids
all day long and guess what i am not
failing
because i'm doing what's right right now
and on the days when i don't work and i
play with my kids and we go on picnics
and we have ice cream
not failing at my job because i'm doing
what's right
right then what's right
right now when you give yourself the
clarity of knowing what that is
the discipline to actually spend your
time on it and the permission to be
present for it
y'all you shake the guilt from all the
things that are not right right now and
you give yourself this incredible gift
of being present for the very moment
that you're in you not only get to
experience your life more you get to
enjoy it more
you actually get to be proud of how you
spend
your time what's right right now
but how do you do that on an ongoing
basis like how do you how do you know
what the right things
are maybe that's a hard question for you
you're like i don't even know what i
want i don't even know what my season is
i don't even know
how i'm supposed to resist the pressure
to do everything everybody else wants me
to do i don't know how to manage my
calendar how do you say no
without being a jerk like is that
possible how do you
how do you stop staring at your phone
when it just is so
addictive and we pick it up over and
over and over again without even
realizing how do you stop that negative
voice in your mind
that still creeps up even when you're
doing the right things
how do you deal with that like how do
you live this out this this doing the
right things at the right time
creating balance your version of balance
how do you live that out
in a practical way you know what
i love practical i love taking
complicated difficult ideas elusive
ideas that kind of haunt us
and boil them down to a simple
definition and simple
steps i love making things practical
and actionable where i give you a
step-by-step plan
to do the thing i'm telling you to do
and you're probably not surprised to
hear this but that's exactly why i wrote
my book
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance this is my new book
you've probably heard me talk about it
i've been talking about on the ramsay
show talking about it on the christy
wright show
but this book is that plan
i walk you through five specific steps
that when you follow these steps it
shows you how
to live your life according to this plan
how to do the right things
at the right time to create your version
of balance we talk about priorities we
talk about setting the calendar we talk
about saying no without feeling guilty
we even talk about how do you know
if something's right or not or how to
know when your season changes
or what do you do when your season
changes but you still have commitments
from the last season we talk about all
that and a whole lot more
and if you want to go ahead and order
your copy of my book you get
the ebook and audiobook and a ticket to
my event in september
for free as a thank you for pre-ordering
because it helps us a whole lot
when you pre-order so if you want to get
your copy
of my new book and i'm about to answer
y'all's questions but i want you to know
this before we before we jump into
questions
if you want to go ahead and get your
copy of my new book take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance
there is a link in the chat
on youtube facebook and twitch hey guys
just learned about this um you can click
the link and get your copy and when you
do it will be mailed to you
on september 14th you can always give
away the audio book
i read the audio book which was super
fun by the way or give away the hard
copy and you keep one copy
give another one to a friend but it
helps us with our pre-orders
and it gives you some fun freebies and
bonus items and then we're also having a
live event in um september september
16th where i'm gonna be doing a full
event
with dave ramsey we're gonna have a live
audience here and also do a live stream
that you'll get a ticket to if you
pre-order
your copy if you wait until it's out you
don't get any of that fun free stuff so
go ahead and get your copy and i'm going
to jump into you guys uh questions now i
know some of y'all have been sending
them in so i'm just going to jump in
from the
the first ones that i have and if you
want to hang out with me we're going to
do this for about 10-15 minutes and
answer your questions i'd love to hear
from you
all right uh hannah asks i would love to
hear your stance on the mom guilt we
feel from doing things that are
necessary for ourselves
but that take time away from our kids
well i love how hannah said it's
necessary because we understand
with our mind that something is
necessary be it rest
self-care date night vacation time alone
whatever
here's one trick that will help you and
this is for all of you that struggle
with guilt
mom guilt dad guilt doesn't matter if
you have kids or not there's guilt
i realized that so much of my guilt
always came from focusing on where i was
not
so when i was at work i was worried
about kids like oh my gosh i'm did i
miss field day did i forget their lunch
are they sick are they sad am i a bad
mom but then i would go home
and think about work oh i missed the
email miss the deadline i've got to
finish that writing project i'm staring
my phone checking an email on my
computer
i was always focused on where i was not
when i was at work i thought about my
kids when i was at home i thought about
work and i was always focused on where i
was not well
let's acknowledge if you live your whole
life this way
of course you feel guilty because you're
always focused on where you're not
so a simple trick that you could do is
flip your focus i know this sounds so
simple but you can actually
intentionally do this
with your focus be where your feet are
so that means that when i'm at work
i think about work and if those thoughts
creep in about what a bad mom i am or
what my kids are doing i redirect my
thoughts to what is right right now
work what is right in front of me work
what is right right now you me and you
in this awesome live session i'm not
thinking about my kids
but when i go home tonight and i crash
after having a very long day i'm going
to spend some time with my husband and
go to bed and tomorrow i'm going to play
with my kids
i'm going to sleep in maybe take her to
waffle house i don't know we got plans
i'm not going to be thinking about you
i'm gonna be thinking about them
so flip your focus to be where your feet
are
when you're at work be at work when
you're home be at home when you're with
friends be with friends wherever you are
be there and watch how this simple trick
of flipping your focus to where
you are not only helps you shake the
guilt because you're no longer feeling
bad about where you're not
it allows you to experience and even
enjoy more the moment that you're in
so flip your focus i love how my friend
tony used to say and i wrote about this
in the book
he used to say i'm always driving to
somewhere that i love
when i'm driving home i'm driving to
somewhere that i love and when i'm
driving to work i'm driving to somewhere
that i love
what i love about that perspective was
tony was focused on where he was going
not what he was leaving behind flip your
focus
to where you are wherever you are be
there and that will help you shake that
guilt
it's not a perfect formula we all feel
that creep up from time to time
but watch how that helps you
tremendously shake some of that off
all right um alicia says i run a small
bakery out of my home i also homeschool
my three pre-teen children
i'm wanting to grow my business but i'm
really struggling to find the time how
do i do this without feeling like i'm
going crazy
well first of all are you ready for it
you don't find time you make time
here's the thing your time alicia is
finite
you've got 24 hours in a day i want you
to block the hours that you need to
homeschool
if that's your number one priority and
see what other hours are
available if the hours aren't available
to grow your business
then you need to reassess your goals
because sometimes like my grocery
example we have unrealistic goals we're
like
on a saturday we've got a to-do list of
47 things you can't do 47 things in a
saturday
unless you're putting away 47 toys and
each one counts as an item on your to-do
list listen this is not possible
so when you have more on your to-do list
or more on your plate or more on your
counter then
the expectations are more than the time
can physically
hold you set yourself up to fail so a
simple practical thing you can do
is actually prioritize what you want to
do and allocate hours for it i talk
about this in the book
but many people especially women calling
you out
we treat everything as if it's created
equal i'm gonna do this and this and
this and this and this and this
and then when push comes to shove and
two things compete we can't make choices
listen flip it you need a list
top to bottom not left to right this is
not a horizontal line
it's a vertical line or a pyramid if you
want and you write
number one is this number two is this
number three is this so
if i do nothing else i want to get this
done first this done second and so on
then if you don't make it number five
or number 45 you're like okay i got the
most important things done
first simply having a set of priorities
will help you make decisions
it will give you peace of mind it will
help you be more proud of how you spend
your time
and it will give you so much more
confidence in your choices because you
know
you're doing the right things um
jesse asked how do you say no when you
want to
how long do you guys have because i got
another good hour teaching on just the
word no
i'll spare you my soapbox but here's
what i would encourage you
two things number one understand
that saying no does not mean that you're
a jerk
you can say no in your sweet
southern christian enneagram 2
personality you can say it
however you want to you can say it in a
way that's true to you it does not make
you mean
it does not make you a jerk it does not
something you have to apologize for
justify or explain
let me give you an example i've shared
this before but my husband says this to
me all the time
and he's so nice the answer is still the
same i might come home with a new idea
i don't know i have a hundred ideas a
day i come home with a new idea
hypothetically to get a dog
or redecorate our entire living room or
move across the city whatever
all potential ideas maybe i've had in
the last couple months anyway
i come home with one of these new
awesome ideas and i say to my husband
babe you know what we need to do right
now this is so great like
this is what we we need to get a dog
yeah i just i feel it like it's like
mary grace loves dogs like we're dog
people and it's been a long time since
jackson passed away like
yeah we totally need to get a puppy okay
here's my husband's typical response
wow babe that is so interesting
um i don't think we have the bandwidth
to add an additional responsibility
to our lives right now in this season
but i do
love how you love animals and we'll
definitely talk about it again sometime
so nice the answer is the same no we're
not getting a stinking dog christy like
no this is not our season we can't even
keep our
children wrangled right you can say no
without ever even saying the word and
you can say it in a way that is kind
and true to you but here's the second
thing i would say so it does not make
you mean you can say it in a way that's
nice
the second thing you need to know about
saying no is that this is something
you have to practice you have to
practice
in front of your mirror in front of your
husband in front of your dog if you have
a dog i'm so happy for you maybe one day
i'll have a dog
practice in front of anybody anywhere
practice
saying the word if you never practice
then it's hard for you
because it's a muscle you never exercise
and like any muscle you don't exercise
it's weak at first
the more you practice the easier it
becomes
so i just want to encourage you this is
a skill we all have to love
love and and use we have to learn
because
if we don't learn this skill everyone
else will dominate our calendars
in our lives and you'll end up resentful
and unhappy
you want to be a nice person you want to
be a good person
let me tell you an honest no is always
better than a dishonest yes
let your kindness show through in how
you deliver the no and how you live your
life
true to your values and you don't let
that resentment build up
when you're saying no when what you want
to say is yes it's a skill you can learn
and a muscle you can exercise
and we also talk about that in the book
on setting and the chapter on setting
boundaries because we all need work on
that
all right um denise says what do you do
when everything feels like the right
things
i have a full-time job i'm 42 and in
college i have a major life experience
going on with one of my children
and need to be helping my spouse with
his side business because we're trying
to get out of debt
so denise i hear what you're saying and
many of you may relate to denise because
denise has a lot going on
a lot of good things going on just
because you have a lot of things going
on doesn't mean it's bad
you can be balanced and be busy i'm very
balanced very busy
the key is putting the things that are
important to you in order of importance
so in your example denise i don't see it
here anymore it disappeared but in your
example nice like you've got
you've got college you've got your
husband's side business you've got all
you've got a full-time
job you've got all these things going on
i want you to put them in order of
importance
now know that in a season here's what
the priorities list might look like but
on a given week it might switch
let's say for example that when you make
this list hypo hypothetically
the very bottom of the list of your
responsibilities is helping your husband
with this business
he's able to run it for the most part
and you you've got to do college first
you paid for this i'm making this up you
decide but but hypothetically here's the
order in your husband's number five
but let's say there's one particular
week in september where it is like
crunch time for him he's got a ton of
orders he's got it's like deadlines it's
crazy
well your husband's side business can
come to the top that week you do what
you need to do on your schoolwork
everything else bumps down you say this
week my priority list looks like this
in a given day this is what my priority
list looks like so within a season you
will know what are your top three to
five priorities
and then as you make this list you make
decisions based on that
so it's not that you can't do all of
those things you just can't do all of
them
every day for the same amount of time so
for example
a clean house is important to me when i
tend i don't know if y'all like this but
i
feel like the state of my house when my
house is put together i feel put
together when my house is a wreck
i feel like i'm a wreck and so taking
care of the house is really important to
me
may not be everybody it's not right for
everybody but it is important to me
so work hard for it in certain seasons
that is something that just simply falls
off the priority list
this is one of those seasons so when i
walk through my house in this particular
season
when i am launching a book i'm in
seminary i have three kids age six and
under and i have a full-time job and a
lot of interests
when i walk through the house and my
house is a mess or my bedroom is a mess
i don't beat myself up for that because
i i remind myself what's right right now
christy you're reading 300 pages a week
of textbooks of words you don't even
understand in seminary
like you're doing great over here what's
right right now seminary
book kids these things not keeping a
perfectly clean house
so remind yourself what's right right
now and then whenever you have that
priority list when things drop off the
bottom
you realize at least you got to the most
important thing so still again
it has to be an order of priority and
then it helps you make decisions of like
well is this really a priority or does
this not fit on the calendar there's no
room for it
you have permission to shift that as
your season changes
as your week changes as your day changes
you have permission to change your mind
change your plans change your priorities
you can and you should
adapt priorities are not a fixed thing
i i talk about this in the book but
every time i talk to priorities
talk about priorities people and some of
you i'd be willing to bet someone has
put this in the chat
if you put this in the chat already let
me just say that i love you i'm not mad
at you but i am going to make fun of you
for a second
every time i talk to people about
priorities here's what they say well my
priorities are simple it's god
other self in that order and amen
like that is a wonderful sunday school
answer
that is very impractical for denise or
myself
or any real lifetime management what is
most important today
i don't know about you but gabriel's not
on my shoulder going hey girl this is
next
i need a plan do you need a plan listen
if the spirit
leads you to go help a person sure your
plan goes out the window but all the
times that the spirit's not leading you
and gabriel's not on your shoulder and
god is not speaking
to you from the heavens about what
you're supposed to do next with your
calendar or your to-do list
you need a plan that plan is called
priorities
you need priorities you need to know
what to do and guess what it can change
by season by week by day even by hour
things can i i might be focused on work
and if i got a call right now that my
son was sick and going to the er i would
say bye
and i'd be out of here to the er your
priorities can change
they will give yourself permission to
change your plans
change your priorities change your mind
um mariela says what about if you have
zero support from your significant other
and you work and are a mom and a
housewife all in one package
mariella i want you to know that i'm
sorry
that you feel alone in that that's a
really tough place to be
and i want to tell you too that's not a
time question that's a marriage
question it's a question that i think
deserves a conversation with your spouse
at minimum
ideally a counseling session or two or a
lot
because you don't feel valued you don't
feel seen
you don't feel supported i can hear it
in your question i don't even have to
talk to you to know that
anybody else that's in mariella's shoes
i would say the exact same thing to you
there's no calendar that will fix that
you talk to a counselor
you need to connect with your spouse and
you need to get the support you need
from a
loving husband in a marriage where two
people support each other
i hope you do that
lonnie asks i'm currently going through
baby step two and working two jobs how
do i fight exhaustion
and get the right things get to the
things i really love to do
lonnie you're in a season that's hard i
talk about this in the book as well
there are some seasons that just suck
we just want out we're looking for an
emergency exit and there's nothing
delightful about this season it's just
exhausting or it's a wilderness season
that god's taking you through or it's
just difficult
in some way two things i want to remind
you that this
is a season it's not forever
whatever your end goal is if it's
however far down the line is you're
going to pay off your debt that you're
done
working those two jobs there is a light
at the end of the tunnel
and when you get there you're not going
to have to work as hard as you're
working right now
so know that this is not forever
remember your why of your vision of what
you're doing this for
it's not forever it's just a season you
can get through this season the second
thing i would say is because you asked
about
how to get to the things you really love
to do focus on
quality over quantity so even if you
can't do things you love to do every
single day
you can squeeze it in once a week and
even if you can't do it all day
that week you could squeeze in a couple
hours so i don't know what that is for
you
i don't know if it is having time alone
reading a book going on
on a cheap date with your spouse or um
you know just going for a walk around
the neighborhood i don't know what that
is for you but find
ways to integrate things you love to do
that bring you joy that fill you up
and re-energize you in addition to the
obvious that you need sleep
um but focus on quality over quantity
just a little bit will fill you up just
a little bit
that's true for you that's true for me
that's true for any of us we don't have
to have a ton of time on these things
but we do need to integrate them into
our lives
if we're going to feel filled up
refueled especially for that tough
season
molly asks how do you stay present when
when you're doing what's right right now
molly it's so fascinating you asked that
because there is a research study i cite
in the book and it's from harvard and
here's what this
study shows that our minds wonder
all day every day so you might think oh
that's just me or just because i'm a
woman or just because i'm creative like
my mind ordered no no all humans
all humans um jenny allen and her book
get out of your head
sites that we have between 30 and 60 000
thoughts a day
so if you're gonna have 30 to 60 000
thoughts a day and by the way you're
going to have a device in your pocket
that's screaming your name all day every
day just
asking you to be distracted from the
moment you're gonna need a defense plan
right like you're gonna need a plan to
bring yourself back to where your body
is
so i know this is so simple and
practical
but when i find my mind wondering
which happens 100 million times a day
for the record
but when i find that happening i try to
catch my thoughts
and ask myself what's in front of me i
know this is so dumb y'all i realize
this
i'm like i just sound like a crate
what's in front of me you are right now
what's in front of me what's in front of
me if i'm driving what's in front of me
i'm driving my car what's in front of me
the computer screen that i'm going to
type
you know some writing on what's in front
of me my daughter's grabbing my legs
what's in front of me my husband's
telling me a story from work what's in
for me what's in front of me what's in
front of me
ask yourself that one million times a
day and it's not that you just do it
enough and you never have to do it again
because our brains are
are wired to wander but it's going to
take you bringing them back to the
present over and over and over again and
it does get
easier it becomes habit where you begin
to catch them more frequently they
wander
less and you're able to be more present
and what's fascinating is this harvard
study showed that the more
your mind wanders the more unhappy you
are
regardless of the activity so you
actually are happier
research shows when you are present in
the moment
even if the moment is mundane
but here's what's fascinating all when
you start to do this because i've
started to do this like
really intentionally i know this sounds
crazy
you not only experience the moment that
you're in while you're in it
what a concept and you not only enjoy
it more which i think we would all like
you actually feel more alive
and i know that sounds like all the
woo-woo stuff i'm not one of those
people but like
we don't realize how much we're just
sleepwalking through life how much our
brains are disconnected from our body
how much we're thinking about things
over here and scrolling phones over here
and our body is here
and there is something very very
unbalanced
uncomfortable chaotic when our mind is
not where our body is when you can bring
your mind back to your body simply
mindfulness
presence focusing on what's right in
front of you regardless of what that
activity is
you truly feel more alive you take in
the sights and the sounds and the senses
and the textures and like you you feel
back at home in your body you feel more
alive
and i don't know that just feels like a
good idea
whether you want life balance or not
stills like a good
thing to be where your feet are so as
simple as that is ask yourself what's in
front of me
what's in front of me and watch how you
begin to see
and notice and experience and enjoy
what's in front of you a whole lot more
all right we've got another question
here from jacqueline a lot of women are
trying to be super moms wives and run a
business
what advice do you have for women trying
to do it all
i would ask you would you rather be
super mom
or be fun would you rather be super mom
or present would you rather be super mom
or actually enjoy your life
i used to try to be super mom i still
slip into that temptation
every now and then but what i realize
now is that
i just want to enjoy my life i want to
play with my kids and not rush through
it
if i've got 30 minutes between things i
don't want to cram another thing in to
rush from this to this to this and also
i can cram this
and fit this in i can also do this on
the way and multitask this in
no i might just let there be some margin
margin for spontaneity
margin for fun margin for joy margin for
slowness
where if my son wants to take an extra
long time telling me a story
i'm there for it or if someone stops me
in the hall outside to talk
i'm not breezing past them let's stop
and talk
it's a great book called ruthless
elimination of hurry that taught me a
lot about rushing
i think that idea not wanting to rush
i've started to prioritize that over
wanting to get it all done
i'd rather not rush than be super
productive
turns out it's way more fulfilling y'all
so i would just say what do you what
would you rather you can keep trying to
be super mom
and wear that cape and impress everyone
and you're exhausted and i'd and i'd be
willing to say if i can tell you this
tough love i think you're setting a poor
example
for your friends because you're holding
them to the expectation that they need
to be super mom too
and your daughters if you have them
maybe prioritize something else
maybe instead of being super mom you
just want to be you and enjoy your life
i think at the end of our life that's
what we'll have wanted we wish we would
have done
it's out y'all it's out it's for real
i mean pre-order it mails to you on
september 14th take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance if
you click the link in the chat
and get your copy now it will be mailed
to you september 14th
you will get a ticket to my event on
september 16th and
you will get the ebook and audiobook
free as a thank you
for helping us because pre-orders really
really help
us with our marketing and help us
hopefully fingers crossed
make a list of best sellers which is
such a fun goal for our team and myself
that's worked so hard on it
this is a book that i want to set you
free it's a book that i want to shine
hope
into places that have felt hopeless and
exhausting this is not a productivity
book this is not a book about how to do
more
how to be more efficient more productive
this is a book with five
practical steps of how to do the right
things at the right time
how to create your version of balance
how to actually enjoy your life
i love you guys thank you for giving me
your time by hanging out with me tonight
i'm so grateful to get to spend this
time with you and i hope you get your
copy and i hope it helps you
create your version of balance i hope
you'll have an awesome night thanks doll
[Music]
you